oh [__] smoky smoky it's that time
concept is smoky smoky
we got the bronchitis killer right here
it's already working the Mules debt it's
Tuesday night our home Tuesday night so
you're looking forward to us coming into
your [__] living rooms [__] cuz
we ain't doing much that means you ain't
doing much all right if you're an 18
hang up now you little [__] go
read a book you [__] we ain't got time
for Scrabble here tonight
this is [__] killer night tonight we
got everything
quality ambulance we got my sugar the
tablets we got it all don't worry about
the [__] nurse there's like a mass
suicide way all we did is Jim Jones and
this [__] you don't say it is
what it is [__] strap on your
seatbelts the church is coming your way
you little [__] [__] the holidays
is over No
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me or what
showing up with this [__] beauty of
death look at this look at the back of
this [__] crystals coming from
everywhere you stick this up your ass
you'll be walking into doors for four
[__] days that's how we're going
tonight you follow me uncle Joey here
direct from the Sugar Shack smoking
reefer we got the edibles
we got the stars of death we got a
couple mushrooms left Lee says he wants
to give him a try tonight BK he wants to
inhale the [__] bronchitis thing with
the mushroom what he think of these
things
look at that remember that John we had
to butch [__] welcome to the [__]
holidays I left some for Santa [__] that
[__] that's cool oh he's a baby
stems hmm delicious nutritious you do
whatever you want [__] I talked to my
jujitsu TG said he [__] ate him and
it goes dog
I usually don't see [__] cuz I saw some
[__] you don't say Joe Alvarado the guy
from the podcast got his [__] strike
you hear how that thing cracks it don't
taste like like maraschino cherries we
ain't got time to [__] around here to
church you wanna [__] around go to your
local coffee house and tell your friends
how you gonna go to Bangladesh next year
and whatever the [__] you're talking
about
this is uncle Joey TV [__] we
don't go to Bangladesh and nothing but
worry about right here that Kareem could
knock a bomb anyway we just found out
today he dropped the bomb on himself and
[__] that dumb [__] so how you
gonna act if the [__] if your rims ain't
clean anyway you're always [__]
hydrating when there's drugs involved
good I forgot about you gotta be a
[__] burglar get this [__] open look
at these things these are throwing
helium from every [__] direction
tonight we got some food here uncle Nick
we got everything bread all we needs to
stick of butter that's over but I still
got 10 weight watcher points left so uh
and then burn home my vodka tremendous
Hey there he goes there he goes
he's going down drink drink exist boom
there you go down the hatch nobody's
feelings Gary gonna puke on the table
[__]
okay drink it drink it drink great
quickly just drink it without thinking
thinking what I'm thinking
[__] what I'm saying it's that type
of night hold on what we're gonna need
some mushrooms I had to put the right
[__] music huh you got a right to
have the right ambiance I'll be right
back it's the first week and we're
already mushrooms [__] you know
why cuz that's how we do it with a
little [__]
BAM oh [__]
who's eaten another [__] ring-dings
these are ring things where I come from
you know I'm saying these like nut
they're like a [__] aperitif you
[__]
[Music]
there's the organ before the devil shows
up oh [__] it's that time [__]
that's the thing about the church you
know no no you don't know what's gonna
go down
all these little half of [__] huh will I
do mushrooms on the full moon it's a
full moon in my world every [__] day
we get down
7:24 you come into the Sugar Shack aka
Voodoo Lounge
you don't know what's gonna happen even
Cosby's victims will leave here going I
don't know whatever that's how deep we
go [__]
[Music]
you're gonna fly and you're gonna make
it if we try they're gonna love you the
body of Christ [__]
[Music]
look at that God Mort the band is just
fantastic
oh [__] a little Pink Floyd wish you
were here one of the greatest house ever
put on a [__] vinyl they should have
[__] Jesus so they showed up for this
[__] you linear and if we tell you in
the name of the game boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
you want to get down and you want to
[__] get down you want to get down
with the [__] King of Swing or you
want to keep partying with these [__]
amateurs that talk and they don't do
dick nothing they can't run into Voodoo
Lounge you won't even see them in the
Voodoo Lounge does any you can't touch
nothing you touch it you just positive H
you know that you come into this [__]
tight on people come in here and three
days later like you gave me heroin I
tested positive arrow you touch the
[__] chairs in here you never know
what's going on here at the Sugar Shack
aka Voodoo Lounge but pump is cheap it's
time for another bump inhale annoying
right or wrong booklet go ahead antelope
are selling cool I said it a little bong
it and everybody's [__] happy right
or wrong
[Music]
[Laughter]
you want to get down and you want to
[__] around huh [__] all these people
with that [__]
[Music]
anyway during the East Coast blonde that
winter jagged [__] it's all oh
but the shout you guys are [__]
[__] quit your job tell them suck my
dick come on leaving the [__] I'm
getting groceries a [__] bored Texas
come now this thought that you and big
words to really scare the [__] out of
white people vortex mix it into a
cyclone what the [__] whether that's the
two feet of snow just give it to me baby
next thing you know you're hanging out
some guys skiing next to your [__]
cross-country skiing
iceberg the line avital oh you know the
rules no skiing up Burger Line Avenue
[Music]
that reef is bringing the mushrooms to
life is [__] what are you [__] nuts
or what 20 of life no-parole for this
[__] a dude anyway we're here we'll
quit keeping it simple the basics couple
mushroom ease a couple bong hit ease and
a few other abilities you don't say it
just like that nobody gets their
feelings hurt nobody ends up in a rehab
nobody knows nothing you see a couple
[__] flashes you jerk off the
mushroom comes out of your helmet juice
and you're back to normal you might take
a [__] at two on the way but it's all
good we got some arrabbiata we got a
little bonus in there for what uncle
Nick gets here we got some Italian bread
and it's [__] the Tuesday night lunch
I'm [__] in the Church of what's
happening now either you're in or you're
[__] out darkness a little aqua
fresca from the [__] yards of Newark
anyway would you say time for a storm
but you took the words right out of my
[__] mouth you know why cuz you
people are on it you keep me on my toes
when I'm [__] slipping and the animals
ain't happen you always make a
suggestion
you guys love my [__] go-to guys I
dedicate this Jam - you [__] savages
[Music]
are you [__] nuts
this as good as it gets but if you got a
mushroom take it if you if your dad's
got diabetes or by the Lewises foot he's
got some good pills take one of those
[__] things chance Columbus did
should couple be listen you go in your
mom's medication you take three of those
pills and a beer something oh babe I'm
saying something it's your blood
pressure might drop you know you might
start twitching out of one eye but
listen who's higher than you is better
than you ever think of that [__] I'm
[__] up oh [__] they move yet I like
my stars a little mold on that's a you
know you get your money's worth I'm
saying
blue skies from pain
can you tell agree here we go here we go
oh [__] you're heroes for girls
cool breeze called cover with change
did you here we go
the album walk outside
or leave
my man Maurice your Verado anyway
there's more flack came from we got
[__] job baby [__] read for here
this is the [__] that will make your
child start twitching it's the heavy
duty boy right in like I said this
one-stop shopping you're here with uncle
Joey when I'm [__] around you know
what
woody original good heads people [__]
State Farm we are the good hands people
you follow me I'm not for your tools
until I see where little nice take I
take here we go I wish I wish you were
here
oh [__] - lost some swimming in a fascia
bajo year after year oh [__] this
relaxation fungal Joe couple bonnets
some Floyd are you kidding me wish you
were here
what'd you say time for a bucket then
hey listen don't show up here with
accusations alright I'm a man of many
convictions but don't show up here with
accusations because if I take my [__]
if your phone goes Bing and I'm looking
for you right that means we're gonna get
down I'm not gonna waste your time look
at this reasons I [__] you
it's you and me against the [__]
world you understand me I beg you
[__] doesn't wanna get down
when you hear that beg from uncle Joey
you get the nice ready cause you might
pass out something good might happen
let's do another [__] upon it and we'll
talk about particular lady understanding
[Music]
I'm gonna fill up the bong nice no
aggravation is no dramas look at it nice
we still got bronchitis but it's alright
he gave up this body first room tonight
tougher than death he is you understand
me he knows he knows don't [__] around
here if we're giving off something it's
because it's [__] solid understanding
[Music]
that the Bombardier pilot the bombardier
there's nobody on the island that's type
of [__] anyway the [__] we did our
little thing right we've seen the devil
tonight we got a little high we have a
little chance to [__] chat and that's
it now we get ready for the podcast
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz that's the
place to be [__] we're not
[__] around tonight you follow me
utilities like be acquired by put your
feet up and brush the dog [__] you uncle
Joey's coming over for a snack put some
[__] coffee and some [__] danishes
or something
[Music]
that's a little [__] bottle anyway you
know I love your mother [__] this to the
podcast night is brought to you by blue
apron [__] Fuji sports.com go-to Fuji
Sports if you start you Jitsu if you're
a fat [__] 85 or 86 like me bang out a
Fuji 15% off pressing Church CH you are
CH also you know me dog on it they got
me the alpha brain with a couple bonnets
you're tip-top Magoo you remember and
[__] from inside your mother's womb you
follow me you still remember the
wallpaper [__] stomach lining and
[__] anyway whatever you wanna do we're
doing we're going to Austin Texas
January 18th to the 20th Saturday night
late shows already sold out so get to it
[__] don't come crying to me
later Joey I didn't see the tweet ain't
no tweets no more these [__]
have beat me to the punch then the
following week when Charlotte North
Carolina ain't [__] around so let's
do this [__] do this [__] you know I
love you [__] well I chew I got
nothing we're starting off the year I'm
the right [__] foot when I [__]
stopping for nobody we're not bowing our
heads for nobody we're bound for nobody
we're coming out to [__] jump like
Run DMC in 84 we don't give a [__] jack
what you dick it's what we think that
[__] matters anyway
we're about to start this [__] thing
so get your [__] together go take a piss
take a [__] wipe your ass [__] hell
old pushy your muffler whatever the [__]
you're doing and we'll start this thing
off in a couple minutes I'm gonna run
for a little weak coma for a minute here
I'm a little [__] up we hit the
[__] drums a little too hard off the
jump
[Music]
but that's how we do it in the church
because we don't want no
misunderstandings never right Lisa
we get down with the get-down you know
how we do it simply my didn't get my
mummy my bingo ayah and that's your guys
attitude when you leave the house or you
manic and my mom a lot big guy that
means somebody's gotta suck my [__]
fight Oh
anyway the rightful [__] in Studio City
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz by the
[__] is the place to be
we'll see you in about 15 [__]
minutes strap on a pair with time 8
o'clock tick tock [__] will see
you in 10 minutes